[Musique]
salut à tous Underdogs le retour après
quelques saison en standby nous revoilà
pour parler des prospects qui peut-être
ne seront pas appelés en juin prochain
mais sur lequel on a un intérêt tout
particulier donc on va s'intéresser à à
deux joueurs pour ce premier numéro mes
acolyes sont HUG avec notre twitcher fou
que vous retrouvez le le vendredi salut
HUG comment ça va et ben écoute hyper
heureux de reprendre cette petite Clairé
qui nous a vu briller avec des joueurs
qui sont soit en NBA avec un deuxième
contrat soit en prison donc pour
l'instant je suis je B moyenne soit en
prison soit en ProA aussi on avait parlé
de vooueur de San Diego steate qui qui a
été du côté de Strasbourg justement je
meen rappelle c'était Julien qui nous a
qui nous en avait parler et qui est là
avec nous salut Julien salut pierre
salut HUG tout à fait et ben écoutez les
gars très hâte de recommencer cette
petite série très dark dont on va parler
de prospects qui vont peut-être finir en
Chine ou peut-être à Taiwan ou dans
d'autres championnats exotiques mais
c'est aussi ça le charme de s'intéresser
au au prospect on va commencer tout de
suite avec HUG HUG on va aller direction
la NCAA arkansa on va parler de Calif
battle parle-nous de lui ah je suis
tellement heureux là de parler de Calif
battle non c'est pas bien qui prend le
micro je suis désolé pour cette
imitation dégueulasse non mais je suis
trop heureux de parler Calif battle
parce que c'est un joueur qu'Alex notre
notre papa envergure m'a fait découvrir
a 3 ans et ça fait 3 ans que j'essaie de
de le caser un peu partout euh c'est mon
nouveau mon nouveau chouchou donc hyper
content parler ce soir Calif battle moi
pour je pense qu'il faut mieux le
connaître et je vous propose un petit
jeu he comme on a fait dans les podcast
five stars 80 pieds avec avec HUG je
vais vous proposer messieurs et ça vaut
aussi pour le public attention jouez
avec nous chez vous trois anecdotes il y
en a deux qui sont fausses il y en a une
qui est vraie attention c'est pas
évident Julien je sais qu'il est pas
encore
coutumé attention Julien parce que tu
vas voir c'est vraiment compliqué euh
première anecdote Calif battle sa BD
préférée sa bande dessiné préférée c'est
is no good deuxième anecdote
ouais je sais je sais je commence très
très fort deuxième
anecdote son pseudo sur fortnite c'est
Calif Battle Royale
ouais c'est possible c'est possible
attention trisème anecdote c'est un
arrière d' 1,96 5e année NCA 3e fac
après Butler après temple maintenant con
ça et euh qui fait 79 kg et qui s'est
pété le pied au moins 19 fois alors à
votre avis monsieur laquelle est vraie
et lesquelles sont fausses allez Julien
à to l'honneur
Mo je suis pas fun moi je choisi la 3
moi je gagner et franchement détective
he le mec il est très très bon très très
bon parce que moi j'ai hésité beaucoup
avec moi-même avec la une et la de
clinique première intervention c'est ça
on reconnaît le talent ah ben il était
indispensable là on voit le le mec qui
regarde des des conférences vraiment
très
obscures euh plus sérieusement Calif
battle donc ouais un arrière 1,96 79 kg
qui joue cette annéeca qui fait partie
des 43 mecs euh qui ont changé de fac
pour aller àc ça à croire qu'ils ont un
un compte bancaire
illimité on va pas poser de questions
là-dessus au niveau du contexte de son
équipe il sort du banc alors c'est un
joueur qui est beaucoup sorti du banc il
a toujours été le meilleur meilleur
score de son équipe mais tout le temps
une sortie de banc des problèmes à noter
tout de suite avec les autres équipes
qui a quitté Butler il fait 1 an il y a
covid il dit je suis pas content je m'en
vais temple il fait 3 ans il sort du
banc le coach le déteste parce qu'il est
insupportable euh et il décide de ne
plus venir à l'entraînement et de plus
venir jouer et il change d'équipe ça
c'est pour vous situer le garçon
maintenant euh que vous avez un peu le
contexte il évolue avec des joueurs d'un
tout autre calibre euh fort porteur de
balle à côté de lui des arrières
expérimentés un autre joueur Tron Mark
don on parlera peut-être un jour
attention spoiler et un intérieur Brazil
qui ne vient pas de Rio de Janeiro mais
qui va peut-être s'installer dans pas
mal de Mock Draft notamment au premier
tour à côté de lui et son point fort
pour pour parler de ce qui fait plaisir
c'est de mettre la balle dans le panier
et ça tombe bien parce Queau basket ball
c'est un peu le principe du jeu
clairement c'est un scoreur incroyable
Calif bat c'est un joueur qui peut
marquer de toutes les positions euh il
est à 43 % à 3 points cette année alors
il peut faire une semaine à 15 % la
semaine d'après à 90 % en prendant 4 par
match c'est un pyoman de de grande
envergure euh et puis joueur très fort
pour déclencher des fautes près du
panier joueur très très bon pour finir
dans des situations improbables je très
très bon pour varier le rythme donc
voilà au global un
scoreur scoreur quelqu'un est-ce qu'on
peut parler de scoreur trois niveaux
pour lui c'est le terme qu'on aime bien
utiliser B c'est comme je te dis c'est
d'une semaine à l'autre quoi une semaine
il est scoreur TR niveaux la semaine
d'après il est scoreur un niveau voire
de niveau tu vois genre il va alors au
tir à TR points je pense que ça va le
faire parce que cat shoot très efficace
il a accepté de jouer sans le ballon il
a une mécanique qui est rapide qui est
compacte qui part effec ement distance
NBA est capable de se réaxer donc ça pas
de souci près du cercle comme il fait
des choses très complexes euh tu as tu
vois PEL il commence la saison avec 43 %
près du panier ce qui est minable et à
côté de ça il a un f weight de 85 % ce
qui est du jamais vu ça veut dire que
quand il vaer il y a faute il tire plus
de lancer Fran prend l up donc c'est
c'est pourfin jamais vu alors on est
encore que sur si match hein donc voilà
c'est vraiment ces deux forces le
mi-distance c'est plus forcé c'est
vraiment pour provoquer les fautes donc
il va sentir le contact et puis il va te
lâcher trois jambes en avant parce qu'il
a trois jambes Calif battle c'est un
surhomme et il va envoyer une grosse
saucisse en espérant qu'on siffle ouais
moi de ce que j'en ai vu ce que j'ai
beaucoup aimé chez lui tu en as parlé
c'est son tir sa mécanique de tir qui tu
l'as dit très rapide déjà et très
tonique aussi je le trouve sur sur sur
les jambes c'est très très tonique euh
et donc du coup ça part très vite aussi
qu'est-ce que donc tu nous as parlé donc
de ça qui étaé premiè qui était de
mettre la balle dans le panier comme tu
l'as dit je suppose que côté défense il
est moins efficient sinon tu l'aurais
mis en avant ouais il a pas alors temple
il fait pas d'effort mais l'équipe
entière ne défend pas on a vu que sur
quelques possessions un peu sérieuses il
peut il peut se mettre dedans euh mais
voilà c'est pas un joueur très concentré
là-dessus et même encore cette
annéeca assez peu de d'implication mais
encore une fois une équipe
collectivement qui défend pas
terriblement donc point faible et puis
deuxième gros point faible et c'est pour
ça qu'il a jamais été avant considéré
dans la draft c'est les blessures euh
j'en ai parlé mais au lycée il rate sa
2è année de lycée entière pour blessures
au pied euh ensuite il fait une année on
pas de chance covid l'année d'après il
va à temple blessure au pied 3ème année
blessure au genoux blessure au pied et
là cette année il a donc l'an dernier il
fait une saison complète cette année il
arrive àca avant le avant comment dire
le début de saison il se fait encore le
pied donc il revient pour le début de
saison mais voilà on a un joueur qui a
un passif de de blessures vraiment déjà
hyper impressionnant il serait en France
la cql dirait on arrête tu
vois comme tu l'as dit donc k battle tu
tu peux rappeler ces mensurations s'il
te plaît parce que justement voir ce qui
dans la projection et serait capable de
faire et me rappeler aussi son année
s'il te plaît ouais pas de souci alors
donc 1,96 79 kg ce qui a noté c'est que
il est arrivé sorti de lycée 79 kg il va
sortir 5 ans plus tard 19 kg donc on a
pas une prise de masse alors évolution
au niveau du corps mais pas de vraie
grosse prise de masse parce que trop de
blessures donc il essaie de rester léger
et assez peu de travail physique euh
j'ai pas l'envergure il a pas été mesuré
comme c'était pas un énorme prospect en
STI de High School il était 3 qu étoile
et du coup 5e année NC donc alors j'ai
pas sa date de naissance du coup mais
c'est un vieux vieux vieux vieux vieux
quoi on est sur le profil Duart en
sortant en sortie de d'école je crois
que c'est un 2000 j'avais j'avais ét
regardé c'est un 2000 je crois ouais
donc un grand-père
évidemment quasiment 23 ans on
rappellera que arkansa quand même ils
ont sorti quelques joueurs on va
rappeler comme ça P Bev plus récemment
gafford Moody Bobby portis Nick Smith
junior en
2023 black évidemment de Orlando Magic
donc c'est quand même une F qui a
tendance à produire des des prospect
assez récemment SICI en sousest
conference Julien tu l'as vu aussi Calif
battle euh qu'est-ce qu'on en pense de
ton côté alors moi j'ai noté
impétueux tu vois en gras sur mes notes
quoi pux ça veut dire qui part dans des
dans des trucs avec violence et et envie
quoi c'est vraiment ça c'est un type il
a du du feu dans les jambes quoi comme
tu l'as bien dit au shoot ça monte très
très vite ça monte un sacré pop il a moi
je trouve qu'il a un premier pas
terrible je sais pas alorséta coupé
pendant un petit moment je sais pas si
tu en a parlé HUG je veux pas répéter ce
qui a été dit non vas-y je suis pas sur
le drible alors qu'effectivement le
drible c'est il part comme je vais le
dire il part vite et puis change de
rythme sur une même main fr c'est c'est
dur à suivre et c'est un enfer à
défendre ouais hyper explosif il va très
vite au cercle et après parfois c'est
est-ce qu'on peut dire que enfin moi ce
que j'ai vu moi je l'ai pas suivi tout
le temps je l'ai vu sur les cinq matchs
là qu'il a fait euh parfois c'est c'est
un peu n'importe quoi quand même à la
fin je peux dire ça ou pas c'est mal
ouais clairement clairement mais c'est
vrai il cherchent la faute euh donc
certains gestes sont un peu sont un peu
étranges mais euh voilà c'est un type
qui est plein de plein de jus et en
défense je trouve que euh ses pieds vont
très vite quand il est en un contre un
il est il est très agressif il a il
remonte sur euh sur l'attaquant très
très vite après peut-être moins bon off
ball moi je c'est plus des questions que
je te pose tu vois sur cinq matchs moi
voilà ce que il est pas concentré il est
clairement pas focus il fait pas
l'effort
les switch particulièement il pas à
travers l'écran donc il a pas défendu
alors comme je disais temple il a pas
défendu pendant 3 ans il est plus
habitué normalement Kana est une maison
assez défensive Eric muselman ancien
coach NBA au Warriors est assez
pointilleux là-dessus mais cette année
comme il y a énormément de de mecs qui
viennent parce qu'ils ont eu des sommes
d'argent très grosse pour être attiré
comme ça on n' pas encoreou cette
identité razerb qui a fait justement
comme tu le disais pierre des des
prospects
NBA reconnu et réputé pour finir
question collégial messieurs est-ce que
vous arrivez à le projeter sur un second
tour de draft ce monsieur parce que vous
m'avez quand même donné des points
positifs quelques-uns mais j'ai
l'impression que les points négatifs
sont plus nombreux notamment un passif
de blessure xxl et un comportement qui
pourrait laisser penser que le monsieur
est compliqué à gérer est-ce que c'est
forcément le genre de gars sur qui on
prend on lâche un un second tour de de
draft au c'est un genre de gars au
talent tu peux l'avoir top 20 tu vois
vraiment genre moi en terme de de talent
je disais l'an dernier déjà j'avais pas
15 mecs meilleur Bendler que lui et
scoreur que lui le problème c'est voilà
blessure comportement après je suis pas
dans le je suis pas dans le vestiaire
mais c'est genre de gars qui va se faire
acheter sur un Touil et qui va salir de
la gleague ça c'est un mec qui va
tourner à 25 30 points de moyenne en
gleague
et et qui va peut-être jamais réussir à
passer le cap NBA mais si le le corps
tient et qui comprend un rôle notamment
plus d'implication défensive euh ça peut
être un vrai vrai vrai bon joueur de
rotation NBA tu as trouvé un comparatif
toi ce de de jouur là si tu te lances
dans les comparatifs ouf compliqué ti du
coup moi je par j'avais en tête là mon
don sibron dans le style de joueur tu
sais qui qui salit tout en G League mais
qui passera pas le cas parce que Ben
hein fait pas d'effort en défense et euh
et euh comment dire pas assez régulier
dans le tir à tris points euh je sais
pas si vous avez un exemple de de combo
garde puissance scoreur il y a un peu de
Cam Thomas ouais c'est ce que j'allais
dire il y d'accord je vois ce que tu
veux dire ouais genre puissant bouli
prend feu à trois points qui a pas
défendu caractère un peu de tu vois un
sale gosse mais un sale gosse qui met
qui met 20 points donc tu fermes ta
bouche et et tu fermes ta bouche et tu
le regardes et tu dis bon bah d'accord
et ouais ouais un peu de Cam Thomas
jamais effrayé par le fait de prendre un
tiers quoi c'est pas du genre de la
maison de de de refuser ce qu'on ce ce
qui est proposé ce qui ne l'est pas non
plus d'ailleurs c'est ça dans sa
sélection de tiers il y a quand même
aussi à boire et à manger quand même
Julien toi tu tu l'achètes ou tu lui
vois une carrière plus
exotique euh pas évident moi j'ai pensé
aussi à Cam Thomas parce que le gars le
premier match que j'ai vu ça cho dans
tous les sens euh mais c'est peut-être
trop facile comme comparaison bien sûr
et puis
euh je sais pas trop je sais pas trop
maisardy Hardy Hardy qui fait du pas mal
à Dallas mais qui avait des on avait des
questions sur la défense sur
l'efficacité près du panier dans des
choix B qui est bien plus jeune he il a
4 ans moins mais ce genre de profil là
façon c'est des mecs si soit ça passe
soit ils disparaissent tu vois je te dis
lui il peut finir dans ma catégorie
finir en prison je vais pas mettre une
pièce dessus parce que voilà mais il
peut très bien ne plus faire de basket
d'ici de 3 ans quoi ouais il il a un
tempérament volcanique mais tu as
l'impression qu'il se qu'il se comment
dire qu' se reféraine vite quoi il Arve
le terrain on le voit il Arve à se
ouis euh messieur est-ce que vous avez
quelque chose à rajouter sur celui qui
veut être peut-être calife à la place du
calife HUG m'asattendu la perche j' é
obligé de la prendre bah oui elle est
pour c'est réfléchi c'est travaillé
c'est écrit sur un petit dans les Hees
de pause j'imagine il est en train de se
dire comment je vais pouvoir lui faire
une pass d' à Pierre et
cetera que on a des choses à rajouter
sur ce ce monsieur parce que vu son âge
on peut dire monsieur ouis que c'est un
joueur exceptionnel il est kiffant si
vous
ne ble allez voir exactement ouais et si
vous avez l'occasion de voir des match
d'arcans ou des match où il y a C battle
il se passe toujours des des choses avec
ce genre de voir donc c'est vrai que
c'est c'est ça pas à voir en tout cas du
coup tiens je te coupe 5 secondes j'ai
oublié de le préciser pardon grand frère
a jouer à Syracuse basketeur
professionnel
voilàus battle le grand frère ça marche
merci pour ce petit point généalogie HUG
Julien on va partir du coup chez les
Mormons comme tu me l'as dit en off pour
me parler d'un Big Man nous t'écoutons
le feu et la glace on passe à la glace
exactement
W Carlson l'intérieur de de Uta de Uta
you en pactell donc c'est un un gros
monsieur et on va dire monsieur aussi de
on fait des vieux aujourd'hui de M 1300
kg je crois qu'il aura 25 ans au moment
de la draft et ouais oui alors ce qui
peut expliquer son son âge avancé pour
un prospect c'est que voilà comme on en
parlait aussi en off il est parti il est
mortmon il est parti à Manchester sous
le soleil de Manchester quelle chance
pendant 1 an euh peut-être même deux je
sais plus où j'ai mis ça euh voilà euh
donc j'ai donné les dimensions il y a un
autre Carlson dans la dans auta mais
rien à voir aucun li de parenté avec Ben
l'autre intérieur des youuts voilà donc
une fac vois comment dire avec une
réussite très très modérée en Pact twes
depuis euh quelques années le nouveau
coach est arrivé il y a 2 ans ou 3 ans
je sais pas il arrivé de UAI state donc
pas très loin avec le
menur voilà pour la présentation du du
groupe moi j'ai l'impression que Uta et
il sort toujours un peu le même type de
joueur en fait j'ai l'impression que
c'est je de voir d'année en année le
même type de pivot grand blanc machin et
c'est toujours les ils ont un peu
presque les mêmes têtes quoi j'ai envie
de dire mais c'est peut-être que mon
impression à moi c'est là c'est là que
tu te dis qu'un cousma c'est une
anomalie hein parce que quel kzma à côté
des Mormons avec ses pulls et ses vestes
roses et ses manches de 2 m il dire mais
c'est qui ce mec là tu vois depuis il
partent en croisade tous les ans ils
partent en croisadepé exact il s'est
émancipé c'est clair euh
ouais c'est vrai grand Lang Lig on en
voit beaucoup dans ce coin que ce soit
dans toutes les Fages de buta là j'en
vois beaucoup c'est vrai mais il a quand
même une par particularité c'est que il
shoot bien quoi pour un grande sa taille
il shoot bien je commencerai par ça quoi
bien sûr
euh donc 58 % au trou choutin je crois
cette année bon les les chiffres sur
quoi il a eu quoi 5 ou si matchs ça veut
sûrement rien dire du tout mais c'est
une c'est une constante chez lui gros
shooterter il peut joter à TR points il
shoot aussi en mid range mais on pour en
reparler euh des moves des MOV poste bas
euh pas mal donc scoreur un intérieur
scoreur peut-être un peu trop à
l'ancienne mais qui qui qui peut allumer
à trois points comme les premiers
cartons qu'il a mis cette année et qu'il
a mis aussi tout le long de l'année
dernière vrai joueur offensif donc euh
et puis on voit aussi de l'intelligence
dans le jeu parce que c'est un bon
connecteur offensif il a il y a pas mal
de
passes à ses à son intérieur à son are
intérieur avec cette année Ling qui est
arrivé de Colorado avec lequel je trouve
qu'il a une bonne bonne relation
euh donc euh beaucoup de qualité
offensive tu l'as présenté pivot
offensif moi j'aimerais qu' tu me parles
un peu de son tir à trois points parce
que je trouve un petit peu étonnant pour
un gars de sa taille dans le sens où
c'est j'ai l'impression sur ce que j'ai
vu c'est c'est un vrai jump shoot en
fait tu par mécanique ouais parce que
souvent les les intérieurs c'est souvent
un tir un peu poussé enfin les les pieds
dans le ciment et lui on a vraiment
l'impression que VO il chote un petit
peu comme un mec qui fait euh 10 cm de
moins quoi
ouais voilà il a un vrai pop alors il
est un peu lent sur le Popp mais comme
il est grand c'est bien quoi il peut il
peut shter sur des gars et ouais il jum
vraiment il a un geste qui finit très
très haut donc ouais je comprends ce que
tu veux dire
ouais assez propre ouais ouais la
mécanique est très belle pour un G bon
après il a aussi quasiment 25 ans
donc il il a quatre épouses il a quatre
épouses h
enfants mar si si il est marié ouais
ouaisro il est marié il a il a des
crédits tout ça euh tu nous as parlé je
trouvais ça intéressant de de bons
connecteurs parce que comme en plus de
ça c'est un peu une des grosses menaces
du côté de de Uta on l'a vu aussi être
capable de gérer un peu les prises à
deux quand
même qu'il attend oui c'est ça ouais
ouais alors il reçoit beaucoup la balle
quand il est arrêté donc on parlait du
TR points c'est pratiquement que du
catch and shoot je crois qu'il a les je
doir quelque part c'est du c'est
pratiquement à 100 % ou pas loin de que
du catch and shoot à TR points il a
besoin de recevoir la balle beaucoup en
quand il est posé et notamment quand il
est au poste ou il est capable de bien
lire le jeu il a il a une suffisamment
de patience pour pour faire des passes
simples pour continuer le jeu ou trouver
son intérieur qui coupe ou un ailier qui
va faire un cut et c'est assez
intéressant moi j'avais eu un peu
peut-être un petit bémol mais je l'ai
sans doute beaucoup moins vu que toi euh
je trouvais que tu m nous as parlé un
petit peu des moves postebas
effectivement il a quand même on sent
qu'il a un toucher j'ai l'impression que
c'est surtout un toucher de sa main
choeuse j'ai l'impression que c'est
c'est très main droite quand même
orienté
il tourne beaucoup ouais il est il est
efficace sur sa main droite tourne
beaucoup sur son épaule gauche euh de ce
que j'ai vu quand il ça tourne sur
l'autre épaule il est il est moins il
est moins facile et il se sert peu de sa
main gauche parle-nous maintenant du du
côté défensif est-ce que il sait
utiliser ses 2 M1 alors moi je dirais
que il utilise surtout sa taille pour
pour défendre mais c'est pas c'est pas
son point fort effectivement on on le
voit beaucoup en en drop il défend
beaucoup en drop en ce début
d'année bon il a fait des matchs où il
met des des cartons il quatre blocs d'un
coup mais c'est pas c'est pas sa
spécialité il est il est assez constant
dans dans la protection du du cercle
c'est pas un gros contreur il est il est
pas très vif moi en fait ce que je lu
reprocherai en défense c'est sa vivacité
il est il a du mal à se tourner à à à
réagir assez vite sur sur ce que lui
propose l'attaquant
et du coup il a quelques comment dire
quelques lacunes sur la sur ce type de
défense HUG tu l'as vu aussi qu'est-ce
que une impression sur ce grand Mormon
ouais je l' pas mal regardé parce que
déjà il nous en parlait l'an dernier
juste dans les groupes WhatsApp et puis
avec Alan ils avaient un petit un petit
King dessus donc on a regardé ça euh
c'est un joueur effectivement qui est
assez cool à regarder profil très
offensif effectivement vrai pick and pop
à trois points vrai menace là-dessus qui
sait qui sait bien l la défense moi
j'aime bien que il voit quand la défense
elle va switcher il va sliper poste bas
très rapidement pour pouvoir finir
lorsqu'il voit que c'est défendu par un
grand et que ça switch je pas il poop et
donc je je trouve qu'il s'adapte très
bien à ce que la défense elle lui donne
euh et ce que j'apprécie pour parler du
du shoot c'est que il est à l'aise que
la balle arrive sur la main faible ou la
main forte c'est qu'il met pas trop de
temps quand la balle arrive sur sa main
gauche pour repasser main droite et
dégainer donc ça peut en faire une vraie
menace sur périmètre sur le périmètre
pardon
euh sur voilà sur l'arc de cercle
complet donc un vrai profil offensif
après de façon très honnête je vois pas
là joueur pour la NBA parce que pour moi
les le côté défensif trop fin euh il est
très grand il fait quand même 97 kg donc
c'est pas c'est pas minable mais il se
fait vite contourner ou enfoncer donc je
le projette pas là ce serait bien sur du
second rideau quoi sinon dans une
défense de zone où il vient mettre des
grandes gifles ouais après il y a encore
ce genre de profil je pense à Luc
cornette j F qui joue de temps en temps
qui pointe le bout de son nez est-ce que
il y a on n pas un peu dans ce profil là
s'il y a un espoir pour lui si on veut
en voir un en tout cas oh bah ouais
ouais très clairement vas-y vas-y J
il faut quand même qu' qu'il solidifie
le le haut du corps c'est moi je trouve
quand même qu' qu'il arrive à à résister
quand il est vraiment au contact il
résiste pendant un moment il se bat
c'est un diesel quand même bon il a que
25 ans mais c'est déjà un diesel il il
met du temps je trouve à à se mettre au
boulot en défense euh après c'est c'est
vrai que c'est pas son truc un pivot qui
défend pas c'est compliqué c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué c'est c'est c'est
surtout c'est pas très moderne en
fait ce que ce que souvent en NBA il
cherche plus des physiques un peu
impactant on n'est pas vraiment sur ce
ce registre là après je te rejoins sur
le fait que je le trouve quand même
assez solide dans le conta notamment
quand il initie en fait quand il initie
en attaque par exemple je trouve assez
solide quand même sur au sol tu vois il
a quand même cette ce côté je trouve
assez dur par moment en fait pas dans
dans tout mais quand c'est lui qui
initie le contest je trouve qu'il a
plutôt tendance à à bien plutôt bien
gérer ou alors c'est moi qui qui m'a vu
tu me dis Julien non moi je pense que
c'est c'est un gar intelligent qui sait
gérer les les les les phases de jeu où
où il veut où il initie tu as raison
après euh moi je dirais surtout que
c'est un bon joueur de enfin c'est un
joueur très correct de un contre un en
NCA tu vois donc il a il s'est patienté
il sait quand il va quand il veut scorer
ou quand il va ressortir ou quand il va
chercher à faire une passe
après initiateur je trouve que c'est un
peu fort quoi tu vois ce que je veux
dire dans quel sens je comprends le le
mot initiateur ouais c'est plus un
joueur un joueur de bout cha quoi voilà
est-ce est-ce qu'on est pas sur un
parcours qui peut ressembler un peu
alors à Orlando Robinson qui est sorti
il y a pas très longtemps de chez toi
fren state aussi euh dans le sens où il
sort il arrive en Summer League le hit
aime bien ce qu'il propose pour mettre
du pop pour mettre pour mettre de
l'écart un jouur expérimenté et il va
rouler sa bosse un peu comme ça en
faisant des touets en faisant des de la
gleague et dans un bon contexte où tu
peut avoir un poste peut-être intérieur
un deuxième intérieur qui qui peut
prendre du contact physique ou une
défense très en zone à ce moment-là on
peut peut-être pour le spacing pour
donner un avantage le faire rentrer 5 10
minutes ouais mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il a trouvé un petit rôle à Miami
pour l'instant et
euh après pour moi il défendait il avait
plus de qualité défensive quand même il
semblait un peu Pau Orlando Robinson
mais il était il était quand même plus
efficace au niveau au niveau défensif et
donc du coup on espère le voir où dans 3
4 ans notre ami Brandon Carson Brandon
Carson
pardon mais comme l'a dit comme l' dit
pas facile hein le la la la porte n'est
pas grande ouverte pour lui quoi il va
falloir qu'il mette le pied et qu'il
essaie de qu'il essaie de se trouver un
rôle quoi il va falloir qu' qu'il soit
efficasse à TR
points qu'il arrive peut-être à ouais à
à à forcer un peu du au niveau physique
pour pour être un peu plus impactant au
niveau défensif est-ce que déjà est-ce
qu'il peut changer de nom parce que
Branden donc B R a n d e n c'est
horrible à dire on l' l'appelit Brandon
tout le temps donc tu peux lui envoyer
un message pour dire change ton prénom
prends brondon prends autre chose
Carlson brondon Carlson voilà on inverse
quelques lettres mais c'est impossible à
prononcer sans se tromper mais il il y
en a plusieurs c'est c'est pas un prénom
isolé j'ai trouvé pas mal de nom comme
ça ça m'a choqué au début mais c'est pas
si c'est pas si isolé comme est-ce qu'il
aurait pas le profil à finir dans un
championnat européen notre ami Brandon
ah si ce serait cool ce serait cool en
plus ça peut jouer plus grand ça peut
jouer des zones envoyer le M en Turquie
bon je suis pas sûr qu'il kiffe en terme
de Mormon en Turquie mais mais pourquoi
pas qui demande des conseils sinon à
notre ami Spencer Butterfield qui joue à
nanter qui vient de Uta qui maintenant
est postier euh je il il a ouvert une
compagnie de poste et voilà pour prendre
ses marques nanter 92 et c'est
parti par Butterfield je m'y attendais
pas est-ce qu'on a fini sur le portrait
de Brandon Carson du coup ouais on a
tout dit là je pense je pense qu'on a
été pas mal ouais ouais je pense aussi
alors si vous voulez voir Brandon en
action c'est faut regarder les agis de
Uta vous l'avez bien compris on n pas
sur
c'est les you c'est les
pardon merci si vous vouz regarder ce
gars qui est très cool aussi avoir joué
parce que beaucoup dans les fondamentaux
un peu à l'ancienne mais terriblement
efficace hésitez pas non plus ça
beaucoup d'œil ainsi va se finir
messieurs ce premier épisode
d'underdogs donc deux jouurs très
différents qu'on vous a proposé on va
vous en proposer d'autres tout au long
de l'année n'hésitez pas à nous faire
des retours à dire si vous avez vu ces
gars-là si vous les avez aimé ou pas
pourquoi on est complètement ouvert à à
la discussion sur X comme on doit dire
maintenant on pense bien à vous on vous
embrasse et on vous dit à à très bientôt
[Musique]
salut